these toads are Impostors they're the
latest example of using 3d printing to
study animal behavior with the first
rains neotropical yellow toads begin an
intense breeding season that can last
little more than a day for this brief
period the male toads switch their
normal drab Brown to a vibrant lemon
yellow this year they will be joined by
a handful of impersonators as scientists
try to find out more about the toads
mating behavior the researchers will
place a female into an arena with two 3d
printed male Robo toads one more
brightly colored than the other by
recording which model the female prefers
they hope to find out how the intensity
of yellow affects the females choice
something previously difficult to
accomplish with handmade replicas
researchers have also used 3d printing
to look at the mating preferences of the
northern map turtle the males are known
to breed with females up to ten times
their mass but is size something these
males are looking for scientists printed
two models of female turtles identical
except for their size and place them at
the bottom of a lake the wild male
turtles attempted to mate with the
larger of the two females more often
suggesting that size is an important
consideration for these Turtles
ornithologists have used 3d printed eggs
to study how robins deal with eggs from
parasitic cow burns that are laid in
their nests with 3d printing researchers
can create cow bird eggs that very
subtly in size and shape and their
research can now be reproduced by others
using the same 3d model once any of
these models have been created
it can easily be mass-produced despite
these advantages 3d printed animals are
still rare in research but as 3d
printers get more common and less
complex you might want to keep an eye
out for wildlife Impossibles
[Music]